many developers certain reuse code from
the web the bank code search Adam for
visual studio 2013 gives a better code
search experience direct inside Visual
Studio after installing the atom when
you trigger intelligence you will see
the how do I button on top of the auto
completion window click the button to
open the code search panel is our first
example we would like to find code to
read the file line by line note that in
the query the variable file is
referenced after hitting enter the atom
shows the suggested snippets the snippet
for example uses the streamreader class
to read the file as we can see the
variable file appears on the right place
the bottom of the panel displays
information about the snippet we can see
the web page where the snippets came
from and their titles you can navigate
through snippets from different content
providers for now we have four partner
websites msdn stack overflow das net
pearls and c sharp 4 11 let me go back
to insert the slip it into my code now I
want to obtain another snippet to
generate the md5 hash code from the
contents of the line variable to do this
I'll type in the query generate md5 hash
from line to make the query more clear
we can specify the type of the variable
and use the @ sign to escape the
variable now as before you can choose
this liquid that you like the most this
time I will choose a snippet from stick
overflow this is the bank code search
Adam I hope you will enjoy using it
thank you